[Music]
three globes cryo facial nurse tea doing
some serious met prep with nurse Jamie
with clients including Jenna Dewan
Jessica Alba Leah Michelle and Kelly
Rowland this is for serving you quick
meet Hollywood's red carpet secret
weapon nurse Jamie she's revealing the
biggest steals and splurges to age
backwards and lays their laser laser I
say forget diamonds lasers are a girl's
best friend if you're up for a splurge
this full face laser treatment that
targets fine lines and stimulates
collagen production will set you back
four hundred and fifty dollars it makes
those tiny little preparations in the
skin your body thinks it's been injured
so it sends new collagen to heal this is
an at-home version of that this has the
smallest smallest little needles 89%
cheaper at fifty dollars this beauty
stamp can also be used repeatedly at
home the great thing about this is
causing those tiny little micro
exfoliation and if you can see that fold
just already start to soften a little
bit but nurse Jamie's biggest tip to
prevent premature aging doesn't cost a
penny don't side sleeve number three
cause of premature aging is hoarsely
puppets including side sleeping so I
always have to put more filler and Botox
on your sleeping side a lot of people
don't know that I always tell my young
clients lives between our pay me later
[Music]